INTELLIGENCE THE ACTING
DIRECTOR JOSEPH MAGUIRE.
JUAN, DO YOU THINK THAT THE
DEMOCRATS SHOULD HAVE WAITED
UNTIL THEY HAD SEEN THE
TRANSCRIPT AND WHISTLEBLOWER
BEFORE THEY MOVED FORWARD AS
NANCY PELOSI DID LAST NIGHT?
>> NO.
I THINK THAT BASED ON WHAT
WE KNOW AND WHAT HAS BEEN
PROVEN, IN TERMS OF THE
RELEASE, IT'S THOUGHT A
TRANSCRIPT PER SE.
IT'S MORE A MEMO WRITTEN OF
PEOPLE WHO UNDERSTOOD OR
HEARD THE CONVERSATION.
I THINK THAT THEY WERE
EXACTLY RIGHT.
YOU KNOW, TODAY APPARENTLY
THE WHITE HOUSE TALKING
POINTS GOT LEAKED TO SOME
DEMOCRATS.
>> Dana: THEY WEREN'T
LEAKED.
THEY WERE ACCIDENTALLY
EMAILED TO THEM.
THAT'S NOT LEAKED.
>> Juan: THEY DIDN'T INTEND
IT SO I GUESS IT WAS LEAKED.
I THINK, YOU KNOW, JUST
LISTENING HERE BOY THOSE
TALKING POINTS THEY HAVE
MADE THE ROUNDS.
BECAUSE THE REALITY IS.
>> Greg: WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN?
WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN ARE YOU
SAYING I GOT TALKING POINTS?
YOU GOT TO ANSWER TO THE
ACCUSATION.
>> Jesse: I WAS TOLD WHAT TO
SAY?
>> Juan: ALL AROUND.
>> Greg: YOU HAD A WHOLE DAY
TO TALK.
LET'S GET KATIE IN AND SEE
IF SHE HAS SOMETHING TO SAY
THAT IS ORIGINAL.
>> Juan: HERE WE GO.
ASKING A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT.
>> Greg: UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Juan: INVESTIGATE A
POLITICAL ARRIVAL IS
ILLEGAL.
>> Greg: DID YOU GET THAT
FROM MEDIA MATTERS, JUAN?
>> Juan: THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD PROTECT AND DEFEND
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES.
AND BY THE WAY, THIS ISN'T
JUST ME.
>> Jesse: SUPPOSED TO LOOK
AWAY FOR POTENTIAL
CORRUPTION?
>> Greg: YOU CAN'T BECAUSE
YOU ACCUSE US OF READING
TALKING POINTS.
>> Juan: JUDGE NAPOLITANO
WHO IS OUR SENIOR NEWS
ANALYST WHAT DOES HE SAY?
YOU DON'T NEED A QUID PRO
QUO, YOU JUST NEED TO ASK A
FOREIGN GOVERNMENT.
>> Jesse: JUDGE NAPOLITANO.
>> Juan: IT'S NOT ONLY THAT
YOU STOP AND THINK ABOUT.
MITT ROMNEY SAID
EXTREMELY -- COMES FROM A
REPUBLICAN.
>> Greg: OF COURSE.
>> Juan: YOU GET A SITUATION
WHERE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS SAYING I
WANT DIRT ON MY POLITICAL
OPPONENT.
AND THEN I HEAR OH, IT'S
BECAUSE WE CAN'T BEAT YOU AT
THE BALLOT BOX.
IT'S BECAUSE HE IS WORRIED
ABOUT JOE BIDEN.
THIS, TO ME, IS OUTRAGE AND
UNBELIEVABLE THAT PEOPLE
WOULD TRY TO THROW --
>> Jesse: LOST THE LAST
ELECTION.
>> Greg: JUAN, YOU GOT TWO
DAYS TO TALK ABOUT IT.
KATIE HASN'T BEEN ABLE TO
SAY WORD.
>> Juan: GOOD FILIBUSTER.
>> Greg: YOU WERE ON THIS
SHOW YESTERDAY WE WEREN'T,
YUAN.
YOU HAD YOUR SHOT.
>> Katie: TALK ABOUT TWO
THINGS YOU BROUGHT UP.
YOU SAID IT IS ILLEGAL FOR A
PRESIDENT TO ASK FOR DIRT.
BUT FROM A FOREIGN AGENCY OR
A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT.
A DEMOCRAT SENT A LETTER TO
UKRAINE IN 2018 ASKING FOR
THEM TO INVESTIGATE
PRESIDENT TRUMP BY
COOPERATING WITH A SPECIAL
COUNSEL INVESTIGATION.
SO, IF TRUMP IS GUILTY OF
IT, SO ARE THE DEMOCRATS.
YOU ALSO.
>> Juan: HE WAS ASKING.
>> Greg: LET HER TALK, JUAN.
>> Jesse: YUAN, DID YOU READ
THE TRANSCRIPT OR NOT?
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE YOU
DID.
>> Katie: I'M GOOD.
>> Jesse: GO AHEAD, KATIE.
>> Katie: YOU IMPLIED THAT
THE TRANSCRIPT WAS NOT
PROPERLY TRANSCRIBED.
THE PEOPLE WHO WROTE THE
NOTES WERE CIA AGENTS WHO
WERE BROUGHT IN FROM A CIA
TO DO THIS.
WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE WHO
ARE -- HAVE DONE THESE
THINGS BEFORE HAVE SAID ON
RECORD TODAY THAT THIS IS
THE CLOSEST YOU ARE GOING TO
GET TO A TRANSCRIBED.
>> Dana: THEY ARE NOT TAPED.
>> Dana: SO ONTO THE
POLITICAL ASPECT OF THIS.
YOU KNOW, THE WORD FAVOR HAS
BEEN TOSSED AROUND A LOT IN
TERMS OF THE TRANSCRIPT.
PEOPLE ACCUSING THE
TRANSCRIPT OF GIVING A FAVOR
AND ASKING FOR A FAVOR OF
JOE BIDEN BEING
INVESTIGATED.
HE ACTUALLY USES THE TERM
FAVOR WHEN HE IS ASKING
ABOUT -- UKRAINE
INTERFERENCE IN THE 2016
ELECTION.
LET'S NOT FORGET IT WAS THE
DNC WHO WENT AND MET WITH
UKRAINE OFFICIALS IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. TO ASK FOR
DIRT ON PRESIDENT TRUMP ON
BEHALF OF HILLARY CLINTON.
THAT'S THE FIRST THING.
THE SECOND THING IS THE
PRESIDENT THIS WEEK HAS BEEN
ABLE TO SET UP A HUGE
CONTRAST TO WHAT IT COMES TO
WHAT DEMOCRATS ARE FOCUSED
ON AND WHAT HE IS DOING.
HE HAS BEEN MEETING WITH A
NUMBER OF LEADERS.
YOU HAD SECRETARY POMPEO
STAND UP AND SAY WE HAVE
CONVINCED A NUMBER OF ALLIES
THAT THE IRAN DEAL IS NO
LONGER THE WAY FORWARD WITH
IRAN.
SO WHILE HE IS DOING THIS ON
THE WORLD STAGE AND HAVING
SERIOUS CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THE SECURITY OF THE COUNTRY,
THE DEMOCRATS ARE FOCUSED ON
IMPEACHMENT BASED ON THE
TRANSCRIPT THAT THEY DIDN'T
EVEN SEE UNTIL TODAY AND
CONTINUING ON WITH THE
NARRATIVE WHILE THE
PRESIDENT IS ACTUALLY
FOCUSED ON SERIOUS ISSUES
THAT EFFECT THE COUNTRY AND
VOTERS ARE GOING TO BE THE
ONES WHO DECIDE IF THAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> Dana: LAST MONTH -- I
CAN'T REMEMBER WHICH POLL IT
WAS.
PRETTY MUCH CONSISTENT
ACROSS THE BOARD THAT 60% OR
MORE OF PEOPLE SAY THEY ARE